foncez de la sécurité nationale on
enchaîne tout de suite avec une autre
audition organisée par la commission
denquête coville il s'agit de la double
audition d'eric maury président de la
société de réanimation française et du
professeur hervé bouaziz hervé bouazizi
les présidents de la société française
d'anesthésie-réanimation regarde
l'audition on en reparle juste après
c'est le président rond mesdames
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs je t'adore vous décrire une
réanimation puisque c'est l'objet de
cette audition une réanimation une
réanimation ce n'est pas simplement une
architecture destinée au soir des
pressions dont le pronostic vital est
engagé
une réanimation certes a besoin de
matériel deux ventilateurs de moniteurs
de pousse seringue
mais une réanimation c'est surtout une
équipe un travail collectif où chacun a
son rôle dans une transversalité qui est
exemplaire
une réanimation ces 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7
deux intérêt pour cette passion un
actionnaire pour 4 patients et un nombre
conséquent de médecins devraient des
professionnels de la rénovation issus de
deux filières l'animation et la médecine
intensive ranimation la réanimation est
centré autour de ses passions qui relève
de la médecine ou de la chirurgie les
passions des défaillances d'organes due
à l'aggravation soudaine d'une maladie à
des complications chirurgicales à un
traumatisme grave ici des soins un
projet pour parvenir à survivre à cette
étape
enfin la rénovation c'est un lieu
confronté à une mortalité d'environ 20%
un patient sur cinq dans lequel chaque
admission et réfléchit en fonction d'un
projet de vie la réanimation est à
différencier les unités selon eux
continuent dans lesquels les patients
sont surveillés car à risque de
défaillance d'organes mettant pas en
défense d'organes des unités de soins
intensifs sont centrés sur un seul
organe des salles surveillance post
intentionnelle prenant en charge les
patients après une chirurgie toutefois
il existe un socle commun entre tous ces
sites qui devraient en cas nécessité
pour être transformée sans délai en
réanimation
de là la conception des soins critiques
et de la rénovation éphémère les liens
sont nombreux en intra hospitalier par
le bloc opératoire et en extra
hospitaliers via la régulation postale
hier qui est un élément déterminant de
la chaîne durant la première vague de
lakovic 19 des soins critiques ont été
mis sous les projecteurs alors qu
environ 5500 lits de réanimation sont
disponibles en france 7148 passion
coville 19 ont été admis durant cette
période durant cette période dit pas son
nom kovy dont des extraits ont également
été traitées la baisse drastique des
admissions notamment liée à
traumatologie a eu pour conséquence qui
est une conséquence du confinement a
permis de passer ce cap
la déprogrammation chirurgicale massive
seul échangé plusieurs genres ayant été
pratiquée a permis de diminuer la
pression sur les soins critiques et a
libéré des professionnels notamment des
médecins et 6 réanimateur et des
infirmiers anesthésistes diplômés d'état
qui par la passivité leur formation ont
concentré leurs activités sur les
relations permettant un renfort
salutaire devant l'afflux de basson
colis de 10,9 des relations éphémères
ont été créés dans les zus qu soin
intensif salle sciences po ce
intentionnel et d'autres sites
permettant d'augmenter le nombre 95 % le
nombre de dons permettant d'augmenter le
nombre de lits de 95% en quelques jours
cette organisation montré la capacité du
système à surmonter un affût brutale de
passion sans encourir de temps elle a
été possible et efficace là où le tibre
où les médecins des établissements
parfaitement collaboré entre eux là où
les établissements privés publics
explique et à chiyah ont parfaitement
collaboré entre eux dans les régions où
cette collaboration a été parfaite
en tant que médecins nous avons été
confrontés à un débat éthique autour la
priorisation des passions entre les
passions commis 19 les passants n'ont
commis 19
nous sommes également conscients en
tomber le saint des enjeux socio
économiques induits par un confinement
l'évolution récente de la situation
appelée la deuxième vague ou marée
montante a un profil différent
l'activité en dehors et en l'hôpital est
extrêmement intense liée au rattrapage
des activités chirurgicales au retard
pris lors de la
du conflit confinement et la
déprogrammation est aussi un nom
important de traumatisés qu'ils sont
notables partout en france
il faut comprendre qu'en cette rentrée
établissements de santé sont sous
tension que la plupart des chu et ch
sont en pénurie chronique de personnel
soignant et médical pénurie
d'infirmières et infirmiers pénurie de
kinésithérapie pénurie de médecins
inscrits matters pénurie je pense aussi
de médecins en sinistres animateurs la
montée du kobe 19 s'est faite sans marc
sécurité avec un personnel à peine remis
de la première vague
nous sommes confrontés à un monde de la
santé concurrentiel dans lequel
certaines activités typiques du service
public ne sont plus valorisé depuis très
longtemps
lakovic 19 qui s'installe pour une durée
indéterminée notre paysage médical met
en lumière les effets d'un système enfin
soyons prudents avec les messages dont
le niveau de preuve n'est pas avéré en
dépit de la progression sera
connaissance de la maladie de la
production de quelques nouveaux
traitements et stratégies les jo aux
installations animations restent
prolonger le pronostic des patients
restent incertains et la hauteur des
vagues de la marée appelez ça comme vous
voulez indéterminée à ce jour finalement
pour conclure je reprendrai ce que le
professeur maurice cecconi de 2000 ans
les présidents de les igloos la société
européenne ramassions affirment ces
jours ci la régulation est une illusion
si des mesures ne sont pas prises en
amont
elle sera comme elle imagine une saga à
rien merci à notre attention
merci see more i
[Musique]
par monsieur monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
devraient d'abord remercié la commission
de donner à la srlf que j'ai l'honneur
de présider l'opportunité de donner
quelques éclairages sur le rôle de la
réanimation pendant l'épidémie qu'ovide
alors la réanimation comme l'a défini
mon collègue marc les hommes aussi la
prise en charge des patients qui
présentent une plusieurs défaillances
d'organes nécessitant une méthode de
suppléants ça peut être la ventilation
artificielle pour la ventilation est
défaillante
ça peut être la l'épuration extra rénale
et quand le rein est défaillant ça peut
être la circulation extracorporelle
quand l'activité cardiaque et
d'effrayantes alors un des points
positifs de cette crise c'est qu'elle a
mis en lumière la réanimation vis-à-vis
du grand public qui était jusqu'à
présent une discipline plutôt méconnue
elle a souligné le fait que les
structures de l'animation devait être en
nombre suffisant sur le territoire elle
a aussi souligné l'importance d'avoir un
coupet personnel médical et un personnel
soignant qualifié alors cette
réanimation cette crise sanitaire a été
a été effroyable et elle a aussi permis
grâce à la grâce au dynamisme des deux
disciplines la médecine intensive
réanimation anesthésie réanimation
permis de partiellement compensé
l'importance de la crise alors je
voudrais revenir sur ces deux
disciplines dont vous avez entendu
parler qui ont toutes le mot réanimation
dans leur acronyme alors la médecine
intensive réanimation là ce qu'on a
appelé la mire c'est exclusivement
dédiés aux soins critiques alors que
l'anesthésié d'animation médecine
péri-opératoire qu'on appellera marsa
comporte l'anesthésié et la prise en
charge non chirurgicales des passions
chirurgicaux est polytraumatisée pendant
leur hospitalisation
alors la crise sanitaire ça a été
parfois ça on a reçu beaucoup de
messages de détresse des collègues delà
du grand test avec des situations où il
semblait que les
et capacité de prendre en charge des
patients a été dépassée malgré des
transferts nombreux malgré l'ouverture
de réanimation ex nihilo
il ya eu des situations difficiles ont
été complétés signal il n'a pas été
facile tout le temps et c'est cesser ces
praticiens ont eu beaucoup de
difficultés à se sortir ces situations
alors c'est vrai parce que la crise est
survenue sur un capacitaire de
ranimation français qui est le suivant
alors va essayer la ligne bleue on est à
un peu plus de 7 lits pour cent mille
habitants
ce qu'un fin capacitaire d'environ 5000
lits de réanimation alors ça aussi entre
5700 et 5000 parce qu'il ya 500 ou 600
lits qui sont forme qui sont fermés
faute de personnel soignant
vous voyez que ça ne nous met pas dans
le plomb de dans le peloton de tête par
rapport à certains de nos voisins
alors pendant cette crise il a donc
fallu augmenter le capacitaire de
réanimation parce que je vous rappelle
qu'au plus fort de la crise il y avait
plus de 7000 patients covin en
réanimation auxquels il fallait ajouter
les patients non covit qui nécessitait
aussi la réanimation
alors tout ça ça a été possible grâce au
dynamisme des anesthésistes réanimateurs
qui comme la déprogrammation
chirurgicale était massive ont pu se
consacrer à la mise en place et la mise
en fonction de l'unité de réanimation
créé ex nihilo et ben ils ont réussi à
augmenter le nombre de le nombre de lits
mais enfin n'y avait pas que qui était
sur le sur le pont la médecine intensive
ranimation a été en première ligne delà
de la prise en charge est clos vite je
vous rappelle que le coc vite c'est une
pneumonie et les premiers malades ont
d'abord rempli les services de médecine
intensive l'animation qui lorsqu'ils ont
débordé ont dû être hospitalisées dans
les service d'anésthésie réanimation et
dans les lits créés ex nihilo mais sais
tu comment dirais-je cette pathologie
était essentiellement une pathologie
médicale et malgré l'absence de
déprogrammation de leur activité les
médecins à temps steve istres animateurs
ont réussi aussi à doubler leurs
capacités d'hospitalisation
alors comme aux commandes devient ton
réanimateurs en 2020 alors il ya 2
voie pour y arriver le premier c'est le
death le diplôme d'études spécialisées
en médecine intensive réanimation qui
dure cinq ans qui comporte une façon
qu'une phase de consolidation de trois
ans pendant lesquels les les étudiants
acquièrent une compétence dans les
spécialités médicales variés une phase
d'approfondissement d'un an le désert le
diplôme d'études spécialisé en
anesthésie réanimation qui est l'autre
possibilité de faire de la réanimation
alors anesthésie-réanimation pète
médecine péri opératoire qui dure aussi
cinq ans qui comporte un parcours
pédagogique spécifique et au terme d'une
formation qui comporte de la réanimation
et d'anesthésié
on estime qu environ trois quarts des
médecins issus de cette filière vont se
tourner vers un exercice de
l'anesthésique en 2016 la réanimation
médicale qui était un desk va devenir un
d eux s et va s'appeler la médecine
intensive réanimation parce que les ds
qui ont été supprimés en 2016 et 7 bat
bien que la discipline est changé non et
continue à prendre en charge les
défaillances d'organes dans un contexte
médical donc des patients à risque ou
qui présentent une défaillance d'organes
donc c'est pas des pneumonies graves
dans le coffee des méningites des
patients qui présentent des comas des
insuffisances rénales d insuffisance
hépatique la liste n'est pas exhaustive
elle est exercée en chu dans des
services de médecine intensive
l'animation à côté des réanimation
chirurgicale et dans les hôpitaux de
plus petite taille généralement nos
universitaires dans le cadre de
réanimation polyvalente dont on estime
qu environ
plus des trois quarts des décès jour
sont des séjours médicaux et non pas
chirurgicaux alors là la relation avec
les disciplines médicales est importante
parce que les pneumologues les
internistes les infectiologues les
cardiologues les néphrologues les
hématologues nous nous transfère
beaucoup de patients pour qu'on les
prennent en charge
il ya aussi une articulation très
importante avec la médecine d'urgence
que ce soit par les services d'accueil
d'urgence ou par le samu et là je crois
qu'il est aussi important d'avoir une
une voie de communication entre le samu
et les
les services de réanimation qui soient
le plus simple possible alors un petit
diagramme un peu compliqué mais que
j'aimerais jouer résume et là c'est le
comité national de la coordination de la
recherche en france qui montre un
diagramme et sur le diagramme ya
plaindront alors je vais juste vous
demanderez regarder le ski est entouré
là ou là où tout en haut et à droite
bon c'est la production scientifique des
chu de 2006 à 2015 et la discipline qui
est le plus haut en la hausse et la
réanimation médicale à ce qui fait dire
à cette commission que la réanimation
médicale agaceront théologie les
pathologies la cardiologie se trouve
dans l'angle supérieur droit indiquant
que les chu excellent dans ses
spécialités avec un impact presque deux
fois supérieur à la moyenne mondiale et
qu'au niveau national il domine
largement la recherche dans ces
disciplines avec un indice de
spécialisation de 4,5 à 5
ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas dans 17
disciplines fondamentales montant des
cip line de spécialités médicales alors
pour essayer de reprendre un peu le
panorama des lits de réanimation vous
avez vu qu'elle la réanimation médicale
enfin ce qu'on appelle maintenant la
médecine intensive l'animation et au
sida réanimation chirurgicale alors les
lilas qu'ils sont vivants qu'ils sont
présents en france ont ventilé un peu de
la façon suivante donc 900 lits de
réanimation médicale qu'on appelle
maintenant la médecine intensive
réanimation trois mille deux cents lits
de réanimation polyvalente dont à peu
près deux tiers des effectifs sont des
médecins milliard et un tiers sont des
anesthésistes réanimateurs et les livres
animations chirurgicale de chirurgie
cardiaque et neurochirurgie son son seul
a pris en charge exclusivement par des
médecins anesthésistes réanimateurs
alors ça c'est l existant et puis ce qui
serait nécessaire c'était peut-être
d'avoir d'aidé personnelle un peu plus
un peu plus motivé pour avoir pour avoir
des niveaux de médecins dans les
différentes structures que je vous
décris là ce qui aboutirait à avoir un
collectif de mettre 2710 mire
sur le territoire et 2420 anesthésistes
réanimateurs pour prendre en charge les
structures de réanimation alors les
besoins de formation médecine intensive
ranimation c'est à dire le besoin d'un
terne bon bah il avait été évalué à
hauteur de 130 postes par an dans la
suite d'une enquête un peu anciennes de
et quand il a et quand le test que c'est
transformer en ds il a fallu donner une
gauche à ce besoin de médecins pour
qu'on voulait former
on s'était fixé sur 130 puis ça a été
ramenée à 120 puis finalement à 60 c'est
à dire que on a perdu 30 % de ce qu'on
demandait et on a 60 interne de
réanimation médicale de médecine
intensive l'animation qui fut sont
formés annuellement c'est notoirement
insuffisant cela survenait sur une
situation d'une spécialité sinistrée où
il y avait déjà un déficit de 300
professionnels et avec saab on
s'aperçoit qu'on fonctionne très
difficilement période normale et basse
tout ça est amplifiée pendant la crise
où la situation peut paraître par
certains aspects catastrophique
aujourd'hui il ya trop peu d'un terne me
reformer pour occuper des postes
d'assistant en me reconnais poste de
chef de clinique en chu n'est poste
d'assistant au ch
le nombre de réanimateurs est
insuffisant c'est majoré par la crise
pilak maintenant que la pandémie est
nationale que les transferts ne sont pas
possibles et qu'on ne peut pas
bénéficier des renforts d'autres régions
on s'aperçoit qu'il est impossible
d'ouvrir des lits de réanimation
supplémentaires sans faire de
déprogrammation chirurgicale donc on
déshabille pierre pour habiller paul
bon c'est un moyen de faire face à la
crise mais c'est peut-être pas
complètement satisfaisant
quand on va se faire opéré d'une
appendicite aujourd'hui je pense que on
a on se pose la question de la
compétence et de l'exercice du praticien
qui va vous prendre en charge
on souhaite quelqu'un qui fasse que la
chirurgie digestive et carnets d'un
anesthésiste dont ces exercices
habituels une métier d'animateur c'est
pareil c'est un métier à temps plein
c'est un métier exclusif au même titre
que le métier d'infirmier de réanimation
dont on a beaucoup parlé on a vu
qu'elles étaient indispensables dans le
dans la danse dans la crise et leurs
fonctions dans la réanimation c'est
indispensable parce qu'avoir des
médecins c'est bien mais si vous n'avez
pas d'infirmiers en réanimation le la
réanimation de ne tourner pas alors il
faudrait en france que cette disent que
cette spécialité soit reconnue acquiert
une reconnaissance une valorisation
comme c'est le cas dans certains pays
européens et il faut se dire que bath
métiers spécifiques c'est pas la même
chose qu'une infirmière de salloum une
infirmière de consultation ou un
infirmier de bloc opératoire ou un
infirme et d'anesthésiques qui ont tous
leurs compétences qui ont tous leurs
spécificités mais qui ne sont pas d un
flamand de réanimation alors qu'est ce
qui définit le métier de réanimateurs
mais vous l'avez compris c'est une
spécialité complexe à l'interface de la
physiologie de pathologie de spécialités
médicales la néphrologie la cardiologie
les bateaux logis j'en pense
j'en passe et qu'est ce qui définit la
compétence mais c'est une formation
initiale de qualité et un exercice
régulier à temps plein de la spécialité
et l'âme hier remplit parfaitement ces
conditions parce que c'est que la
discipline qui est exclusivement dédié
aux soins critiques alors vous ne vous
aura pas échappé que la révolution
médicale se fait vers l'hyper
spécialisation on avait des chirurgiens
généralistes auparavant n'en a plus
maintenant a dit chirurgie 1
qui sont spécialisés en chirurgie
osseuse en survie digestive en charge le
urologique l'ophtalmologie même
maintenant il ya des spécialistes de la
cornée des spécialistes de la rétine
l'anesthésiste est une spécialité
complexe avec des spécificités dans des
dominos avec des tentes avec des
domaines de des domaines d'excellence et
des expertises qui sont très
particuliers en neurochirurgie en
chirurgie cardiaque en chirurgie
hépatique c'est vraiment un métier à
part entière et il faut garder à
l'esprit que même dans des disciplines
médicales aujourd'hui en cardiologie par
exemple quatre ou trois sous spécialité
la rythmologie l'insuffisance cardiaque
les pathologie coronaire les internes
sont mises dans ces filières dès qu'ils
ont à l'internât et il n'en sort plus
par la suite et la réanimation mais ce
que l'on pensé que ce doit aussi être un
exercice exclusif de par sa complexité
je suis moi-même anesthésiste de
formation j'ai pas fais d'anesthésiques
plein depuis 25 ans s'ils ont demandé
dans une situation de crise d'aaland au
regard des malades j'irais bien
volontiers le faire je le ferai en ayant
révisé un petit peu avant et je ne
serais sans doute pas capable d'apporter
le même niveau de compétences et
qualités avec ce qui peut être attendus
en 2020 pour faire une anesthésie d'un
patient alors sans vouloir polémiquer je
voudrais montrer le résultat qui a été
publié au cours de notre vie congrès de
septembre dernier la présentation de
l'expérience de l'hôpital henri mondor
qui a été présentée conjointement par un
médecin anesthésiste et un médecin
intensiviste vous savez que l'hôpital
henri mondor avait un bâtiment qui
devait être finalisé en septembre et que
j'ai eu la crise ce bâtiment était
rapidement équipe et il a pu devenir
fonctionnel début avril
alors ce set l'équipement de ce service
a permis de prendre de monter 43 lits et
de prendre en charge
une bonne bourre nombre de patients
comme étant absorbé comme vous pouvez le
voir sur la sur la diapositive suivante
et encore une fois bon ce n'est qu
observateur n'est mais vous voyez qu'il
est il ya eu deux exercices qui ont été
comparés d'une part un secteur mire avec
une extension du service de réanimation
médicale existants et une section
marquis était formé en grande partie de
médecin anesthésiste qui étaient
disponibles parce que la chirurgie avait
été déprogrammé qui sont venus aider qui
sont venus aider à faire de la
réanimation et on ne peut que les en
remercier et alors que les patients
semblait à peu près comparable en terme
de gravité voyez autant de passion
vont-ils et 92 % des patients très grave
ya des passions qui sont sous dialyse
épuration extra rénale un quart de
chaque côté il ya un quart des patients
qui sont sous etc mais quand on regarde
au final le décès banda on observe que
la mortalité plus importante dans
l'unité qui a été prise en charge par
des gens dont le métier initial n'est
pas de faire de la réanimation
alors je crois qu'on ne fait
correctement que ce que l'on fait
régulièrement et c'est l'exercice
régulier qui dit film qui définit la
compétence et là je crois que les mares
ont peut-être été mis en difficulté dans
des situations qui n'avaient pas
l'habitude de gérer mais encore une fois
on ne peut que les remercier pour ce
qu'ils ont fait dans une situation
difficile on fait ce qu'on peut la
réponse a été de faire de la réanimation
comment le prouver et je vous remercie
de votre attention bien messieurs
merci je vais donc donner à paroles
d'abord aux rapporteurs madame de roche
[Musique]
merci monsieur président et merci
monsieur les les professeurs pour cette
cette présentation
vous nous évoquer nous avait évoqué
brièvement comment vous aviez affronté
la la première vague
comment s'est fait entre vous les robes
comment s'est fait le retour
d'expérience est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous avez fait en interne ou
est-ce que les institutionnels vous ont
aidé à faire ce retour d'expérience
ma question elle vient sur sur commande
dans des hôpitaux différents des vôtres
et d'un des services différents des
vôtres puisque maintenant l'épidémie et
nationales et des patients sont
hospitalisées dans des services sont pas
forcément des services dits de pointe
comment se fait l'information des
praticiens de ses services sur ce qui
doit être fait et pour ne pas avoir à
appliquer des méthodes mais tout de
suite avoir la bonne la bonne méthode
pour pour la ranimation est ce que vous
voyez dans ce rebond une sas et plus
pour la situation actuelle une typologie
différente des patients par rapport à ce
qu'elle était lors de la première vague
et même si on a entendu le président
mille on l'a dit en début d'intervention
qu'on nous dit qu'ils en effet eu des
des techniques de réanimation qui ont un
peu évolué et que les patients rester un
petit peu moins longtemps
ça c'était ma première question la
deuxième c'est ce que je voudrais
entendre
hormis c'est ce que vous nous avez dit
sur des chiffres de lits de personnel et
autres
quels sont les points forts de la
première vague en terme de demande
manque de d'équipement manque de
produits de santé manquent de matériel
qu'est-ce que vous retient briller et
qu'est ce que vous avez fait remonter
pour que ce que vous avez pu subir entre
guillemets au début
ne soit pas le cas dans ces
hospitalisations qui s'annonce merci je
vous laisse répondre alors sur le retour
d'expérience je vous attendrai à dire
que dans nos disciplines il est constant
puisque ce qu'on appelle les crocs un
sens c'est vraiment ça fait partie du
traitement de la culture du soins
critiques et ça fait partie de la
culture alors je vais rentrer dans le
débat de l'anesthésié réanimation
plus largement donc le retour
d'expérience a été fait dans chaque
service je pense dans chaque hôpital il
a pas été formalisé par nos encadrement
administratif si c'était ça la la
question il est naturel dans les
services puissent maintenant je crois
que tout service hospitalier à des
réunions de son appel et rmm les revenus
mortalité morbidité et des réunion de
retour d'expérience
les dons qu'il a eu à des bilans il ya
eu beaucoup de publications il ya eu
enfin c'est le nombre de publications
sur la copie de 19 depuis le début de
l'épisode
c'est tout simplement ahurissant et donc
on a des publications françaises qui
rapporte l'expérience l'ex-nationale
récemment un papier de gens ils le
feront dans le journal de notre
spécialité qui fait un bilan des
hospitalisations et qui est une sorte de
retour d'expériences nationales
l'information des praticiens belle
aujourd'hui elle va très vite elle va
très vite on peut pas la contrôler on
sait qu'on sait pas où on en est
d'accord c'est bon mais on n'a pas un
niveau adéquat
je ne je ne suis pas je vais moi je vais
pas rentrer dans la polémique vous avez
bien compris que mon collègue et ami
puisqu'on est issue la même la même
famille le départ
vous les polémiques et je ne vais pas
vous dire que les ainsi serait amateurs
son meilleur ou moins bon que ce que les
murs et je n'oserais pas aller sur ce
terrain là je trouve ça assez surprenant
mais il y as clie des différences de
niveau entre les réanimations en france
c'est probable voilà c'est probable
selon la localisation selon selon selon
les équipes et par contre l'information
aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux et
avec les cités notamment alors le site
de l'as far par exemple de la série
mation qui a produit des référentiels
tout au long de la crise quasiment en
continu a été une source d'information
pour la plupart de nos eaux de nos de
nos mandants 1 et on a par exemple un
système qui s'appelle habits réa sur
lequel on a été sollicités plus de 200
fois temps dans la première vague c'est
à dire que tous les jours il y avait des
gens qui demandaient que faire et on
leur répondait dans l'heure qui suivait
la typologie des passions alors dois
vous avouer que j'étais de garde cette
nuit encore donc dans une unité de
coheed et moi les passions ce sont les
mêmes ce sont ce sont les mêmes que la
première vague
alors j'entends beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux à la radio dans les médias que
les patients sont très différents pour
moi ce sont les mêmes mais passion ce
sont les mêmes cap que la première fois
c'est je vois pas de différence je les
regarde bien mais sont les mêmes
d'accord et leur évolution est
d'ailleurs assez similaire on a eu
quelques petits progrès la dexaméthasone
dont avec quelques études randomisées
qui montre un petit bénéfice
et puis quelques zones où on était
incertain et qui sont le comme
l'hydroxyde brooklyn et qui sont en
recul mais on a la ventilation avec
l'obstination à haut débit qu'on utilise
un peu plus qu'au début mais finalement
pendant la première bague on avait déjà
corrigé le tir assez rapidement on
s'était tous rendu compte qu'il fallait
utiliser donc entre le début de la
première vague première vague
on avait déjà changé nos habitudes je
pense pas qu'il y des révolutions dans
la prise en charge de ces patients je
pense pas que la dexaméthasone va faire
un effet qu' on ne va plus mourir demain
de lakovic 19 et je crois que les
évolutions
c'est une fois que c'est pas son sort on
intubé et ventilé seront les mêmes
peut-être qu'on aura un peu moins et que
cela on peut être une meilleure
évolution mais autrement une fois qu'ils
sont un peu en ce qu'il est pour nous et
encore une fois je vous dis pour nos
passions qu'on voit qu'on est dans les
yeux les évolutions sont exactement les
mêmes
les points forts en termes de manque on
a manqué de tout il faut être clair on a
manqué de tout et ça s'est fait comme ça
se fait toujours dans les hôpitaux
il n'y a pas de barrière on n'y a pas de
barrière étanche entre les services il
ya pas les mares l'émir on travaille
tous ensemble ça c'est dans les hôpitaux
publics notamment un ça se fait sur la
bonne volonté et l'engagement des
professionnels qui travaillent et
l'engagement des professionnels qui
travaillent a été exemplaire pendant la
première prendre la première vague est
tout à reposer là dessus sur des gens
qui se sont tus n'ont pas compté leurs
heures ils ont été présents qui ont
répondu présent après on a manqué tout
on a manqué de blues on a manqué de
masque on a manqué de lunettes de
protection
on a on était habillée avec d'une façon
qui n'était pas très digne pour un pays
comme le nôtre pour aller pour aller sur
sur ses passions qui sont à risque
contagion élevé et
voilà où on a créé des 10 dans toutes
ses zones de ssp idée parce qu'on avait
pas d'autre solution
d'accord mais voilà ce qu'on a manqué
c'est ce qu'on va pas manquer c'est
l'engagement de nos professionnels qui a
été vraiment à la hauteur
on a manqué de tout en termes de
matériel et heureusement la 1ère bac
s'est arrêté à la limite du moment où on
avait plus de provident anesthésie
quasiment pour assurer la sédation de
ses passions à 15 jours près voilà donc
on ça pose des aurès où de réelles
questions sur notre dépendance à
l'extérieur sur les approvisionnements
en médicaments en matériel en
ventilateurs et tout petit matériel
qu'on peut avoir quand on peut avoir
besoin d'animation
bon je partage eu une grande partie des
choses qui ont été dites par par mon
voisin
on a bénéficié de l'expérience du grand
est à la phase août initial delà de la
crise parce qu'ils nous ont dit que il
était submergé par un afflux de patients
qui n'arrivait pas à contenir il est
anticipé anticipé ouvrait des livres et
des lits parce que vous allez vous faire
déborder ça c'est vrai que ça a été
quelque chose de très fort il ya eu des
recommandations multi sociétal qui ont
été commanditées par la coreb qui
regrouperait la srlf lasfar la société
des infectiologues des urgentistes les
pédiatres et j'en oublie un les
pneumologues et cse ses recommandations
multi sociétal ont été publiés sur tous
les sites sont aussi de laisser aller
sur le site de la soirée ont été remises
en elles ont été remises à jour 4 fois
on s'est arrêté pendant l'été est là on
est en train de les remettre à jour pour
que les professionnels et des données
valides qui soient tamponnés par toutes
les sociétés pour la gravité je suis
d'accord avec mon collègue on a quand
même l'impression que entre
l'oxygénothérapie à haut débit qu'on ne
faisait peut-être pas trop utilisés
initialement parce qu'on craignait de
contaminer tout le monde on s'est aperçu
qu'en réalité si on mettait un masque il
n'y a pas de contamination des soignants
ça on s'en est servi largement
maintenant on met les patients décubitus
ventral série patients qui sont
réveillez se mettre eux mêmes sur le
ventre et on a l'impression qu'on
améliore peut-être un peu les choses
montade tout ça reste à confirmer mais
quand les techniques échoué qu'il faut
passer le patient sous ventilation
artificielle on a l'impression et ça je
suis d'accord avec le professeur layton
caen retombe exactement sur les malades
de la première de la première prise avec
des ventilations prolonger trois
semaines parfois quatre semaines des
complications infectieuses pour les
manques que je vous dirais je vous
dirais la même chose manque de
respirateurs de lits et là il ya eu le
système des cas vraiment marcher tout le
monde c'est tout le monde s'est uni pour
essayer d'ouvrir des lits pour essayer
de les équiper
j'ai eues j'étais en contact avec un de
mes collègues a pas il n'ya pas très
longtemps qui me disait au mois de mars
on a manqué de masques puis au mois
d'octobre on manque d'enthousiasmé
voilà pour vous donner un peu une image
du tableau quelqu'un d'autre oui un ami
merci de
donner la parole alors vous avez pas
posé la question sur l'airé texte en
fait nous on sait on a mis en place
aussi des webinars pour pouvoir
communiquer et notamment avant que la
vague arrive en ile de france on avait
fait un webinar avec le grand est qui
justement avait permis aux régions et
notamment l'île de france de se préparer
à ce qui allait nous arriver il y avait
beaucoup de partage d'informations et on
a beaucoup de communiquer avec l'as far
lsr élèves parce que les patients qui
vont en réanimation sont majoritairement
adressée soit par le samu soit par les
urgences et notamment dans les décisions
les critères d'admission et des
techniques d'oxygénation
on a modifié d'un pratique grâce
justement aux partages d'expériences
pour justement avoir une meilleure
pertinence d'admission des patients en
réanimation et de développer des
techniques notamment d'oxygénothérapie
haut débit pour que certains patients
puissent passer un cap
et justement ne pas aller en réanimation
si on pouvait leur faire passer ce cap
là donc il ya eu des recommandations
deux sociétés savantes de travail
collaboratif qui ont été largement
diffusés améliorer et on fait en fait
régulièrement des sessions communes des
façons justement partagé ses expériences
et avoir un travail commun qui qui
permet de travailler de concert alors
dans les points forts dans ce qui nous a
manqué en plus de ce qui a tout a été
dit au niveau de la médecine d'urgence
également ce qui nous a manqué ce sont
des des transporteurs sanitaires urgents
pour adresser les patients dans les
hôpitaux et et notamment au tout début
de la première vague
ce qui nous a amenés en fait ces
difficultés a été un facteur de succès
au final parce que ça nous a amenés à
travailler avec des partenaires peut
être comparé qu'on n'utilisait pas assez
souvent des associatifs qui permettait
de diversifier
finalement les les acteurs et qui n'ont
pas les mêmes missions entre les
pompiers les ambulanciers privés qui se
sont fortement mobilisés et heureusement
parce qu'effectivement il y avait ce
besoin et associatif qui nous permettent
de gérer le médico-social et d'évaluer
les possibilités de laisser sur place et
de ne pas utiliser à tort finalement le
service hospitalier
mais avant de laisser un patient sur
place de temps en temps on a besoin de
personnel qui a un peu l'empathie du
médico social pour permettre de voir
s'il ya la possibilité de laisser ce ses
patients à domicile ou pas donc cette
diversité diversité d'acteurs a été au
final difficultés au départ mais une
réussite à la fin qui conviendrait de
conforter et ensuite sur la typologie
des malades aujourd'hui au samu centre
on a une augmentation des appels très
clairement on voit l'augmentation
continue des appels pour les patients
suspects au vide avec des patients plus
jeunes qui ne relève pas forcément de la
réanimation mais certains ont des
pathologies graves
moi j'étais de garde aussi c'est tenir
des difficultés clair la difficulté
auquel on est confronté aujourd'hui
c'est le manque de lits de réa et mais
aussi le manque d'unité de médecine pour
adresser à la fois les patients qu'aux
vide mais également les patients donc au
vide et lorsque ça se tend dans les
réanimations lorsqu'on a du mal à
adresser des patients dans les services
de réanimation de ma forcément c'est
l'immobilisation des unités de ce mur
etc des patients qui stagne en lésions
chance or on l'a publié depuis très
longtemps là lover cording qui est donc
la surcharge des services d'urgence ça
entraîne une surmortalité de 9 % foot ou
passion confondues et de 30% pour les
patients les plus graves
donc l'objectif clairement de la
régulation médicale qui a été un qui a
eu un rôle
tu râles dans la gestion de la vague en
phase une parce qu'on n'a pas eu la
problématique ont eu l'italie ou
l'espagne de surcharge d urgence parce
que la régulation médicale a permis
d'adresser les patients directement dans
les services spécialisés sans surcharger
les services d'urgence c'est un point
essentiel qui là aussi est nécessaire de
conforter mais à l'heure actuelle
lorsque il ya plus de place de
réanimation pas forcément la seule
solution qu'on a c'est de mettre les
patients dans les structures d'urgence
qui ne sont pas en nombre en personnel
et en compétences capables de faire des
unités d'hospitalisation éphémère comme
ça dans les boxes de salle d'accueil des
urgences vitales et donc la nécessité
d'augmenter les lidd réa et là on le
sent 1 60% de nos lits à l'heure
actuelle dans le département sont
occupés par des patients qu'aux vide et
on ne peut pas faire des preuves des
programmations comme on a fait en
première vague parce que les packs en
patient qui était semi urgents sont
devenus des patients urgent et donc il
faut qu'on gère ces deux filières
kovy des noms qu'ovide et c'est
essentiel pour la population mais là c
est effectivement ça commence à se
tendre de façon importante
je remercie notre attention oui juste
pour dire merci me donner la parole que
effectivement je pense que le retour
d'expérience il est important là le
professeur nourrit mori mori nous a
présenté des chiffres de mortalité on
sait que les facteurs il ya énormément
de facteurs qui peuvent jouer pour
expliquer une mortalité qui serait
différente entre deux populations
on va pas rentrer dans le débat ça n'a
aucun intérêt pas plus que la différence
entre marc et myrna d'intérêt pour la
population française je pense que c'est
pas ça vous attendais et je crois que ce
qui est important c'est ce retour
d'expériences dont vous avez parlé c'est
vous qui avez sollicité des réponses
quant à ces questions et bien au niveau
de la sphère en en association avec le
cnp d'un cd réanimation est également la
srlf il s a été travaillée des points 10
points en particulier ont été signés par
les deux sociétés
les raies éphémère
on s'est dit comment essayer de tirer
profit de ça on s'est rendu compte
qu'ils avaient des drm éphémère qui
était pas bien la doce adhérer à pérenne
et qu'il fallait changer ça on s'est
rendu compte que il fallait former le
personnel est on en train actuellement
dans les écoles dit adieu mais également
dans d'autres structures de d'essayer de
former un maximum de personnel d'avoir
une espèce de deux listes finalement de
personnel soignant qui ont déjà fait de
l'area parce que le problème il n'est
pas tellement finalement dans les lidd
réa et quand on regarde l'allemagne on
passe son temps à dire que l'allemagne
c'est l'exemple formidable c'est
sûrement formidable allemagne ils ont
beaucoup de l'hydre et à mais en fait
dans le monde diplomatique de début
septembre il ya un article qui est assez
bien fait et qui montrent que les
allemands disent que s'ils avaient eu à
faire face la même chose que les
français il aurait un problème de
personnel donc arrêtons dire dix mille
lits en réanimation de réanimation en
allemagne c on est capable de faire la
même chose en france avec nos us et
unité de surveillance continue
il faut avoir des respirateurs et du
matériel qu'ils soient mis d'emblée dans
ses us et de façon à faire face à de
prochaines vagues parce que c'est pas
encore une fois c'est un non sens de
vouloir adapter les lidd réa à quelque
chose qui est guy on peut l'espérer en
tout cas qu'on va pas être confronté à
ça toute notre vie et il faut donc
raison garder de ce point de vue là les
iade donc on trinquera et qu'elle parce
que les iade qui sont allés en réa et
qui certes comme l'a dit monsieur
maurice elles ont des compétences
particulières et justement ces
compétences particulières doivent être
mises à profit au niveau quand elles
vont aider en réanimation
c'est elle par exemple qui ont monté les
réels effets mère très rapidement parce
que connaissent très bien le matériel
elles ont des compétences sur la queue
réalisation sur la sédation prolongée
sur un certain nombre de points
particuliers et il faut mettre en valeur
ses compétences là pour que ça soit
utile dans les services de réanimation
qui ont besoin d aide
donc tout ça doit être effectivement
travailler c'est en cours au niveau de
la sfar bien entendu encore une fois
malgré ce qu'a présenté pour l'e sour
maury on travaille en excellente
collaboration avec la sf
et il n'y a pas de souci de ce point de
vue là et effectivement sur la typologie
tout a été dit je m'arrêterai là merci
merci c'est bon monsieur juillet merci
monsieur le président merci pour vos
propos très très franc et très clair
qu'ils sont qui sont extrêmement
instructif j'aurais voulu que vous nous
préciser bien les choses sur cette
question des lits de réanimation
il ya trois semaines on a auditionné
mise la santé qui nous a dit on peut
ouvrir douze mille lits de réanimation
c'est le nombre qu'il a prononcée devant
notre commission
j'ai entendu de votre exposé qu'on avait
actuellement cinq mille 700 lits en
france
je n'ai pas exactement compris si
c'était les 600 lits indisponible pour
cause de carences de personnel déduit ou
pas donc est ce qu'on en a cinq mille
sept cent mille 100 ou 6003 mais vous
allez nous le préciser et j'ai deux
questions à vous poser
premièrement combien de l'hydre
animations peut-on faire fonctionner
actuellement au bénéfice de patients
qu'aux vide sans toucher à l'activité
usuelle des hôpitaux en moyenne j'ai
bien conscience que ça va être différent
selon les régions un lait et l'intensité
de l'épidémie mais à peu près combien de
lits peut-on ouvrir on a le sentiment qu
à 1600 là je crois au jour d'aujourd'hui
1630 à peu près on arrive déjà dans de
grandes difficultés
deuxièmement en admettant qu'on re des
programmes à nouveau comme au printemps
massivement les activités hospitalières
combien de lits de réanimation
peut-on faire fonctionner dans ce pays
dans des conditions satisfaisantes
évidemment en termes de personnel est ce
que ces douze mille ou est ce que j'ai
entendu monsieur bouazzi ce qui vient de
prononcer de dire dix mille qu'on
pourrait si j'ai bien compris faire
tourner dix mille lits de réanimation
donc ok il faut nous préciser à ce
moment là à quel prix à quel coût pour
le reste du système hospitalier donc ça
c'est ma première question son lead
réage parce qu on a
de mal tout de même à comprendre quelles
sont nos capacités en la matière après
nous avoir dit tout cet été il n'y a pas
de problème qui aurait tout ce qu'il
faut à la rentrée on n'a pas tout à fait
le sentiment que ce soit le cas
deuxièmement sur la question des
médicaments
vous avez expliqué que lors de la
première vague n'était arrivé un peu à
court de médicaments qui aurait pas plus
que ça dure plus longtemps et par
ailleurs d'autres nous ont expliqué
qu'ils avaient mis en place des
protocoles pour va dire économiser de
façon importante les médicaments
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui
c'est à dire si on devait avoir à
nouveau plusieurs milliers de personnes
en réanimation pour qu'ovide
disposez-vous des stocks de médicaments
nécessaires et pour combien de temps
voilà merci monsieur le rapporteur pour
répondre à la première question je crois
qu'effectivement le capacitaire de 12000
il est possible en terme de l'identifier
de licques ont été armés au cours de la
première de la première vague il ya le
matériel il ya les scop les respirateurs
le mail preuve ça prenne de personnel je
crois qu'aujourd'hui en termes de
personnel soignant en particulier on
avait bénéficié delà du soutien de la
solidarité nationale où il y avait plein
de soignants d'autres régions dans
l'impact et qui était venu aux et des
lacets soignants ne reviendront pas
c'est clair donc là sans déprogrammation
jeu
comprends pas très bien comment on
pourra faire marcher fonctionner ccc
unités de ses unités l'animation au gros
plan du personnel sont des
programmations faire au jour
d'aujourd'hui vous ont peu ou pas armé
et yahia 12 me lie à 12000 respirateur
vont etc
le matin il y a il ya donné combien cent
des programmes et à mon avis on est à
notre capacité maximale d'un an maximum
la wii merci puis pour répondre à une
question sur les médicaments je crois
qu'effectivement s'est aperçu qu'on
avait d une tension sur les médicaments
parce que les commandes se font de façon
très tendue quoi s'est il n'y a pas de
stock
et puis là il ya eu à faire à face à un
afflux de médicaments considérés avec
une demande de produits dans tous les
pays d'europe et puis les fournisseurs
se sont retrouvés rapidement rapidement
en difficulté bon lâche sûr on a eu
comme vous l'avez dit à vis des bd
programme de rationnement et on nous a
dit qu'on j'ai entendu qu'on avait
plusieurs semaines de stocks
de médicaments mais je ne vous ferai pas
je serais incapable de vous dire dans
quelle mesure ces stocks pourront être
utilisés sur apportera donc je suis
totalement en ligne avec le professeur
mourir sur ses réponses pour les lits de
réanimation en effet on peut monter
théoriquement jusqu'à 10 12 me lit mais
on n'a pas le personnel à mettre en
regard aujourd'hui et si on ne
déprogramme pas s'il n'y a pas de
modifications il faut comprendre qu une
réanimation
c'est ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure il ya deux infirmières pour 5 10
donné deux soignantes et dans les
équipes de réanimation pour environ 15
10 va y avoir sept hui praticiens
hospitaliers
c'est un système extrêmement tendue en
terme d'effectif et pour les pour les
hôpitaux
et donc c'est pas des endroits où on
veut peut avoir des on est pas comme
levier comme certaines catégories où on
peut laisser des lits libres au cas où
donc je pense que à peu près toutes les
rénovations enfin au moins chez nous
mais je pense la même chose partout sont
remplies avant d'être de remplissage à
la base entre 90 4 95%
donc il n'y a pas de marge de manoeuvre
une fois que en activité normale on est
programmé pour être remplie à 90 95 %
avoir un livre si vous avez 20 lits
maximum pour prendre une chance mais on
n'a pas de marge de manoeuvre derrière
et moi je suis très surpris d'entendre
ce que j'entendais fois pour former un
réanimateur quel que soit son obédience
il faut cinq ans non je vois pas comment
on peut augmenter
très rapidement le nombre de nombre de
vies parce que encore une fois c'est pas
une architecture c'est du personnel si
les infirmiers qui sont d'intérêt en
réanimation il faut qu'il y est il faut
qu'il est à peu près six mois non
l'ancienneté pour avoir une autonomie
donc c'est extrêmement compliqué de
vente de monter le nombre de dix façon
brutale en dehors d'une appellation
architectural rennes nation mais qui
devrait être absolument pas de sens pour
les médicaments ce qui est pareil je
sois même ligne que le procès amaury on
a été très tendue dans les derniers
rapports ça allait un peu mieux on avait
un peu de stock sans avoir beaucoup plus
de détails
donc pour résumer on est à saturation en
l'animation vous êtes à saturation
au jour d'aujourd'hui on est à
saturation parce que il ya 30 ou 40% ont
parfois un peu plus dans certaines
régions mais les pourcentages et des 50
% qui restent sont occupés par des
patients n'ont que vides
voilà tout à fait monsieur peloux
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ce que vient de
dire le professeur layton et le
président morilles et est juste on est
arrivé au bout d'un système
c'est d'autant plus grave que on avait
tous à peu près la certitude au mois de
mars et avril que ça allait se calmer
d'accord bon en gros c'était comme ça
qu'on a qu'on avait mobilisé on s'était
dit qu'on avait tous accepté dans
l'effort de nations qui avait évoqué le
président de la république le fait des
programmes est bon là aujourd'hui c'est
une autre paire de manches parce qu'on
ne sait pas du tout où on va et on est
arrivé au bout de ce qu'on peut faire
c'est à dire que l'épidémie n'est pas
seulement si tu es common man mars et
avril dans l'est et en ile de france un
peu en dedans les hôtes france est un
peu sur sur marseille
elle est partout donc les renforts qu'on
avait et qu'il faut saluer et qu'on
salue tous sur la citoyenneté
l'engagement des personnels qui ont été
formidables et qui ont su arriver dans
des établissements qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas et qui ont réussi à se
fondre dans les équipes
il ya eu de belles histoires bon
problème c'est qu'on n'a pas cette
réserve
d'autre part moi je rejoins ce qu'on dit
des collègues chirurgien la
déprogrammation
en fait ce n'est plus entendable pour
les malades parce que y'en a qui ont été
opérés avec vous avez tous entendu ces
exemples avec beaucoup de délais sur les
cancers notamment
et donc c'est pas entendable de de
laisser sur le côté des malades dont la
mortalité est supérieure à celle du
coronavirus pour dire on va s'occuper
tout ce que du coronavirus même si je
comprends l'engagement qu'il y a
politique sociale sur sur cette question
alors les réserves on les a pas parce
que évidemment tout le monde s'est
retournée en dix ans on a ouvert un
hôpital de campagne du service de santé
des armées mais services de santé ars
mais il faut entendre ils n'ont pas la
liberté de parole comme nous l'avons
mais ils sont exemptes aussi donc on ne
peut pas on a fait une erreur je suis
heureux de vous le dire ici on a fait
une erreur sur paris de fermer l'hôpital
du val-de-grâce d'accord donc moi je
pense que là il ya vraiment une
interpellation pour rouvrir l'hôpital du
val de grâce et faire des lits et il ya
eu toutes ces fermetures de lits
je n'accuse pas le gouvernement actuel
tel n'est pas le cas nous sommes dans
une commission denquête c'est juste que
l'équation qu'on apportait au cours des
vingt des trente dernières années de
dire la france avait trop de lits
d'hospitalisation trop d'hôpitaux on est
on est arrivé mais même moi je m'en fais
l'autocritique à aller dans un sens
d'économie de santé et toujours plus
d'efficience et toujours plus et nous
allons faire
de l'ambulatoire etc etc et on a réduit
la voilure
on a réduit le nombre de lits 100 milles
c'est c'est énorme pour arriver au
chiffre que mes collègues connaissent
mieux que moi et qui sont une réalité
parce que les urgentistes comme disait
ma nièce rick arrivons à l'instant on
travaille avec eux nous nous sommes les
premières heures et après on doit passer
ces malades aurait animateurs médicaux
pour l'essentiel puisqu'on si la grande
traumatologie aurait dit metter
l'anesthésie-réanimation et on a besoin
d'eux là actuellement je travaille au
samu de paris
la situation est extrêmement tendue sur
l'ensemble de l'île de france
alors on essaye de monter des systèmes
pour trouver des lits de et cetera mais
c'est très compliqué et si on en croit
les courbes et on ne peut que les croire
l'icône mathématiques comment ne pas
croire les mathématiques de l'inserm et
de pasteurs les jo les jours qui vont
arriver vont être très difficiles alors
le problème elle ne de la faire c'est
bien sûr le personnel vous avez entendu
les récents articles très dépréciée
jeunes sur le personnel qui n'en peut
plus là il ya des interpellations
sociale je vais pas vous développez tout
ça mais il ya des interpellations
sociales par rapport à la à
l'attractivité dans les hôpitaux et le
management dans les hôpitaux mais tout
ça c'est lié croyais et je terminerai
juste par là croyez bien à l'engagement
des professionnels de santé qui veulent
vraiment tout faire pour sortir de la
crise parce qu'on sait bien que cette
crise qui est hospitalière c'est donc à
retentissement sur l'ensemble de la
société la civilisation en français est
partout ailleurs on est très engagé mais
on a on souffre du fait que ça fait des
années qu'on sonne l'alertent et qu'en
fait on n'a pas été tellement écouté
voiliers et même si là vous parliez du
problème du matériel des médicaments oui
il faut réindustrialiser la france de
toute urgence pour qu'on soit à nouveau
autonome sur les médicaments essentiels
et sur le matériel
c'est vraiment des ces éléments là qui
sont des éléments de sens politique et
et je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté ce
bouaziz oui juste monsieur le président
un petit complément d'abord je pense que
quand on est au bout d'un système il
faut travailler la prévention parce que
effectivement on se rend compte que on
est en tension importante et c'est ce
qu'avait dit le professeur layton dans
son introduction il avait cité le
président les ics qui avait dit qu'il
fallait tout miser sur la prévention
c'est pour ça que ce soir à ma
connaissance le président de la
république va peut-être établir un
couvre-feu à quelle heure etc ça par
exemple on peut imaginer que la nuit sur
les polytraumatisés ça modifie un peu la
donne dans le sens d'une baisse on peut
l'espérer
en tout cas se contester cette
affaire-là disent que immédiatement il
ya un effet sur une réduction des
polytraumatisés la nuit en particulier
il faut également faire une
déprogrammation intelligente
il faut tirer les leçons c'est
exactement ce que on en revient à ce
retour voilà pour cette double audition
avec mort et le professeur hervé bouaziz
était entendu par la commission d'
enquête consacrée à la gestion de
l'épidémie de coronavirus la commission
va désormais poursuivre ses travaux sera
bien évidemment amené en reparler sur
public sénat rester avec l'information
politique et parlementaire continue sur
notre antenne
[Musique]